théâtres et salles de spectacles vont
ils fermés ou bien s'adapter
les mesures gouvernementales annoncées
mercredi 14 octobre vont une nouvelle
fois impacté le monde culturel qui
commençait tout juste à reprendre
adaptation des horaires ou encore report
des spectacles les acteurs culturels
locaux
en temps de se mobiliser évidemment il
ya des spectacles qu'on va pas pouvoir
présenter mais on va maintenir le
théâtre ouvert et présenter le maximum
de spectacles dans les contraintes qui
nous sont imposées aujourd'hui la la
saison en cours celle qui vient de
commencer en septembre
tout aura lieu s'il faut reporter on
reportera mais les gens pourront voir
tous les spectacles qu'on a proposé on
en aura pas d'autres temps que ceux là
n'ont pas été vus théâtres et salles de
spectacles compte fermer leurs portes à
20h30
objectif permettre aux spectateurs de
regagner leur domicile avant 21h en
semaine c'est plus dur quand même
donc en semaine on se heurte à la durée
la durée des spectacles c'est à dire que
l'on peut pas non plus dire mardis ou
vendredis à 18 heures environ le
beaucoup de gens travaillent
il faut qu'il est temps de quitter leur
travail de se restaurer d'arrivée la
salle de spectacle je pense qu'on va
essayer 19 heures
mais ça pose clairement la question des
spectacles durant plus d'une heure
trente
côté économie les établissements publics
et privés sont impactés de façon
différente les théâtres privés repose en
grande partie sur les recettes de la
billetterie
tandis que les théâtres publics et
bénéficie de subventions dans l'immédiat
on est dans une situation un peu un peu
moins catastrophique que d être des
théâtres privés
mais la question est de savoir lorsqu'on
va avoir 200 300 400 mille euros de
recettes de billetterie en moins au mois
de juin prochain
comment est ce qu'on fait pour
programmer la
la saison suivante en juillet le
ministère de la culture a annoncé une
baisse moyenne du chiffre d'affaires de
25% en 2020 par rapport à 2019 soit un
déficit de 22 milliards d'euros